Who will come out with a product that is more amazing than the iPad 2,...
...with its big, beautiful 9.7-inch screen, super fast A5 chip, all-day battery life...
...and elegant, thin and light design?
Everybody has been wondering this.
Well, stop wondering.
We are.
Today we're announcing the new iPad and it is amazing.
And we are redefining the category that Apple created with the original iPad.
It makes amazing improvements over the most fundamental features of the design of the device.
A new feature of the new iPad: the retina display.
You might have heard that an iPad could have a retina display,...
...but until you see it, you can't understand how amazing this is.
The second feature: an iSight camera.
It's a five megapixel backside illuminated sensor.
We brought the optic system from the iPhone 4S.